[Music]
[Applause]
but i want to bring in mike florio kind
enough to join us from canton ohio's we
got the pro football hall of fame you
know mike i was thinking about a year
ago at this time
john gruden and the raiders you had
urban meyer
you know you know back to coaching you
got trevor lawrence
both coaches are gone and here we are at
the hall of fame
uh how would you if i would have told
you a year ago hey
you know which coach won't be with their
team
this year out of those two you would
have said who
all would have been meyer because john
gruden was going to be the coach of the
raiders for as long as he wanted to mark
davis was never going to fire
john gruden he had three straight years
of no playoff appearances and he was
under no scrutiny whatsoever they were
buddies it wasn't going to happen it
took this other outside issue to force
mark davis's hand and frankly i think
one of the reasons why the gruden emails
got leaked was because if they hadn't
been leaked davis quite possibly would
have found a way to say hey he wasn't
working for us at the time it's
irrelevant to us he's going to continue
to be a member of our organization so it
would have been meyer because we've seen
other college coaches flame out none
quite so
dramatically and entertainingly as urban
meyer
yeah you start to look at this and then
you know trevor i think gets a hall pass
because when you're 22 and you're the
grown-up in the room we're asking an
awful lot of him
uh they brought in players this year i
are you surprised that the over under
his eight and a half wins for the
raiders
what am i missing
well they're in the afc west so they've
got two games against the chiefs two
games against the chargers two games
against the broncos and you've got kind
of a weird spot for this team they made
it to the playoffs last year they worked
their way through that dysfunction they
almost beat the bengals in the wild card
round there was that screwy call on the
touchdown pass to t higgins and then the
raiders were driving late and
they they were better than anyone
thought last year but now you have a
regime change how how often do you see a
playoff team have a full regime change
new gm new head coach new defensive
scheme new faces and a very competitive
division in a very competitive
conference and i think it is going to be
they could be a better team than last
year and go eight and nine so it really
doesn't surprise me all right you're in
canton and so you're in the shadow of
cleveland with the cleveland browns what
is the feeling do you get a sense of
what brown's fans think will happen with
desean watson
well it's been a roller coaster this
week for brown's fans because they went
from feeling relief
on monday when the decision from judge
sue l robinson was that watson should be
suspended six games
to now this sense of foreboding that
because the nfl has exercised its right
to appeal the decision to the nfl itself
and the nfl still clearly wants to
impose a significant punishment on
desean watson and the game is rigged i
mean the union agreed to it this is the
bottom line it doesn't matter who makes
the first decision what matters is who
makes the second decision and judge
robinson gave the nfl everything it
needs from a factual standpoint her most
important
aspect of her decision
were her factual findings because those
are binding on appeal and she found that
he did it she found that he violated the
personal conduct policy in three
different ways she called it non-violent
sexual assault for victims that had
their evidence presented in this process
and now the commissioner can do whatever
he wants or the designee can do whatever
he or she wants and remember this too
dan because it really didn't jump off
the page
the judge basically found that deshawn
watson lied
and that is not going to go over well
with 345 park avenue when you are in a
setting like this and you're not telling
the truth this is your chance to come
clean and get a lesser punishment if you
don't come clean the punishment is not
going to be reduced
uh
i think you said that you think the nfl
is going to drop the hammer
and this is i think they are i think
it's going to be
yeah i think it's going to be full year
okay
now if you're let's say in your lawyer
if you're with deshaun watson
what do you do now
today that maybe can help
circumvent or mitigate a year-long
suspension
well i mean today short term what i
would try to do is convince the
commissioner to exercise his ability to
designate someone else and hope that
that someone else can be prevailed upon
because if it's ultimately the
commissioner handling the appeal why
would it be less than a year if the
employees who ultimately report to the
commissioner have been consistently
asking for one year
i assume they got their directive
somehow some way from the top of the
organization so if the guy sitting at
the top of the organization who has
previously said yeah go try to get a
year yeah ask for a year if he's the one
making the decision it's more likely to
be a year so i would try to craft a
letter or do something to try to try to
shame him into
handing it to someone else who may be
slightly less biased not as close to the
action maybe somebody who hasn't been
involved in making decisions about the
league's approach to this that's all you
can do for now otherwise it's sit back
and wait all right football wise
the cleveland browns will they be
content with jacoby brissette
as opposed to maybe trying to go out and
bring in jimmy garoppolo if desean's
down for a year
well that's a great point dan because
earlier this week the head coach kevin
stefanski was asked about whether or not
they have multiple plans based upon what
the ultimate decision is and he said
they do and i thought all along okay
brisette makes sense if it's six games
if it's full season
that changes your analysis
and
i think they are sort of in the we'll
cross that bridge when we come to it
mode
but if they do find themselves in a spot
where watson is out for the year and
there's nothing they can do about it how
do you not consider what would be a
win-win garoppolo gets a year to come in
and play he can re-establish his career
and then go off somewhere else as a free
agent next year when watson comes back
the the only the only hitch is this
they got a fifth round pick for baker
mayfield they can become a fourth round
pick and they're paying 10.5 million of
his salary when they unloaded him to the
panthers i don't think they want to get
hijacked by the 49ers and the best
timeline for the browns would be
they don't find out that watson's out
for the year until after the 49ers cut
jimmy garoppolo but i don't think the
plane's going to land that way i think
the browns are going to know if they
lose him for the full year while the
49ers still have garoppolo under
contract unless they trade him to
somebody else and then that ends the
whole question give the audience an idea
of how long this appeal is going to take
that when would a ruling happen with the
commissioner
tomorrow is the deadline for the union
to submit its paperwork in response to
what was submitted yesterday by the
league there's no hearing on appeal
there's no new evidence the evidence is
already done and it's favorable to the
nfl
the cba and the personal conduct policy
require an expedited process but it
doesn't say three days five days
whatever just expedite it like hurry it
up and it makes sense because
people need to make plans the browns
need to make a plan people need to know
what's going on and there's still that
possibility dan
of the nflpa doing what it did for tom
brady doing what it did for ezekiel
elliott going to court to fight this and
along the way trying to get a temporary
injunction
aimed at allowing desean watson to play
while this all works out but if that
happens because a big misconception
about this he won't play week one
because his six-game suspension isn't
being challenged unless the nflpa
decides to challenge that and they've
already said they won't this is about
week seven not about week one that's a
great point mike florio pro football
talk live co-host and his book play
makers how the
nfl really works and doesn't available
online wherever books are sold a
best-selling book uh help me understand
what happened with the dolphins and
stephen ross and why tom brady and his
agent
weren't punished at all with the
tampering
well typically when it comes to
tampering it's only the teams that are
potentially in trouble if they are
speaking to people when they shouldn't
there's never been punishment for those
who are tampered with players that would
have to be part of the nflpa bargaining
process and it's never been a crime
under the league's rules to be the one
who's tampered with
so even though brady
for four straight calendar years was
tampered with by the dolphins and dan
listen the buccaneers tampered with him
in 2020. other teams tampered with him
and i mean everybody was tampering the
patriots didn't care they didn't want to
have an ugly divorce with tom brady they
knew he was leaving they weren't going
to to be sticklers for the rules there
but it was so blatant it was so bad the
nfl had to do something you throw peyton
on top of it sean payton the former
coach of the saints talking to him
before he even resigned as coach of the
saints so they had to do something in my
theory on that too dan
they wanted to get stephen ross for
tanking but they knew they couldn't
because that opens other cans of worms
they don't want to get into so they got
him for something and the tampering was
so blatant they couldn't look away and
they punish him and even when you look
at what they did the punishment really
wasn't that bad when you consider how
severe the tampering was and how long it
lasted this is like al capone and income
tax evasion i mean that that's really i
if i when i read this and the
commissioner's tone with the dolphins
they were tanking
it's semantics and how you know and and
i agree with you guys if i open up that
can and we now have people doubting the
integrity of the game and the bottom
line of winning games and gambling i
can't allow that to happen it's almost
like let me shift this over here to
tampering and i you know we're not gonna
you know
i'm gonna be railing on this meanwhile
over here this about tanking this is
purposely trying to lose games to better
your draft selection plain and simple
he said it they found that on numerous
occasions the owner of the team said
that he believed
it was better to improve draft standing
in 2020
than to win games in 2019 and the only
thing that saved him is brian flores
said i'm not going to do that he made
his belief clear that's why he fell out
of favor with stephen ross because he
refused to go along dan one of the
benefits of being a multi-billionaire is
you never have to order a code red all
you have to say is gee you know i'd
really like to have a calzone for lunch
and you're going to have a calzone for
lunch you don't have to tell anybody to
go get it it's going to show up that's
one of the benefits of being that rich
so he did everything that he could do
to get the people who worked for him to
do what he wanted he wanted joe burrow
he wanted joe burrow badly and the
people who work for him specifically
brian flores didn't go along with it and
what a shock he ends up firing brian
flores
good stuff mike thanks for joining us
have fun there in canton
thanks dan that's mike florian pro
football talk live the show that
precedes hours on peacock